oh wow you look hey okay you look  miraculous  thank you Wow I can't believe it  okay so first off I'm just thinking  maybe um maybe some prayer okay  Oh turn that maryfayce married this way  I'm gonna just talk to Jesus right now  okay okay  beautiful did I not tell you that you're  gonna be the cover the cover the cover  oh my god isn't this unbelievable like  oh my God look great you have no idea  how much of a rock star you are  I can't wait is Oh ray who's ray Ray's  my fiancee Oh so actually now that I  think about it do you maybe want to  change your outfit because you're gonna  be on the covers yeah anything should  show you yeah oh gosh I'm gonna go put  on the mommy recalled smiley shirt oh  yeah you'll stay right here I will I'm  gonna be famous you are  all right here we have got one more do  this jump on my back right I got it  well  Leila come on what Sam  bluh  damn  you